welcome back now I'd like to introduce
an odd couple Who am I to talk in their
latest film that's alright I can wait in
their latest film he plays The Secret
Service agent assigned to protect a
tough-as-nails manipulative former first
lady who treats everyone around her like
dirt
I believe the working title was guarding
Nancy
please welcome Shirley MacLaine and
Nicolas Cage
we are here tonight to present the
nominees in a very important category
sound you see them on location and on
sound stages some with headphones and
tape recorders twisting dials and
yelling quiet you see them seated at
huge consoles pushing buttons turning
knobs and fading faders they are the men
and women who put the talk in talking
pictures who capture and balance and mix
and match every decibel that goes into
the final film you may never hear of
them but everything you hear in a film
begins and ends with them they are the
proud members of the sound Department
the nominees are
Michael Minkler Bob BEMER and Tim Cooney
for the cliffhanger Donald Oh Mitchell
Michael Hrbek Frank a Montano and Scott
D Smith for the fugitive
Chris Carpenter GM Hemphill Bill W
Benton and Lee Orloff for Geronimo and
American legend
Gary summers Gary rod strong Shaun
Murphy and Ron Judkins for Jurassic Park
Andy Nelson Steve Peterson Scott Nolan
and Ron Jenkins for Schindler's List the
Oscar goes to Gary summers gary rides
from Shaun Murphy and Ron Judkins for
Jurassic Park
I'm so proud to have a small part in
bringing this very special piece of
magic to the screen thank you to the
Academy to Bob Jackson who's worked with
me for 10 years and of course a Steven
Spielberg who made it all possible I'd
also like to thank the Academy Universal
Studios director Steven Spielberg the
folks at Amblin producers Kathleen
Kennedy and Jerry Mullen associate
producer Colin Wilson picture editor
Michael Kahn supervising sound editor
Richard hems great crest of sound
editors Skywalker Sound north and a
great support staff up there and all our
family and friends
thank you all his first Oscar was for
the French Connection and his second was
for last year's Unforgiven here is gene
Hackman